the rise of the delta variant is forcing
some tough decisions at the state level
nevada issued an emergency directive
this week
mandating mass indoors and 12 counties
and california indoor masks are a
recommendation in all but two counties
where they
are required anna warner spoke to the
governors of those states steve sisilak
and gavin newsom
as they surveyed wildfire damage
do you believe that the mask mandate is
going to work in light of the
delta variant or are you worried that
it's not going to be enough
well i'm clearly worried you don't know
if it's ever going to be enough but i'm
confident that it'll work and i'm
confident we're throwing
everything we can at this virus both
these governors say that while masks are
an important tool
they're focused on increasing
vaccination rates to prevent future
surges
and keep the economy open we're putting
everything we can
non-pharmaceutical interventions like
wearing face coverings as well as
dealing
with the biggest challenge we have in
this country that's the misinformation
we're actually going door to door in our
under vaccinated communities but we need
to do more on the education front
california will require masks in schools
this fall
it's proven to be a touchy issue for
governor newsom who's the target of a
september recall campaign
just this week a parent advocacy group
that's suing newsome's administration
over school masking rules
says they found a photo online of
newsome's son with other kids maskless
indoors at a basketball summer camp in a
statement the governor's spokesperson
said the newsomes had missed an email
saying the camp would not enforce
masking guidance
and pulled their children out but newsom
told us
my son went to camp with his mascot and
took it off for a photo had it in his
hand
and we pulled him out of the camp you
want to attack me attack me
don't attack my son a new poll found
that likely voters were almost
evenly split along party lines on
whether to keep newsom in office
we're going to defeat it it's a partisan
republican back recall sisilak has also
faced criticism for weighing in on
reopening decisions
when he promised to give control to
county officials and the pandemic
continues to potentially
impact the political futures of both as
they decide
what measures are enough to control the
virus will both of you
rule out shutdowns again i don't think
that we can rule out anything at this
time we're studying the science we're
following the science we don't ever want
to go back
to physical distancing social distancing
and mandates
we can end this pandemic in this country
once and for all in a matter of weeks
by simply doing the one thing that we
have in abundance and that's taking
advantage of these life-saving drugs
these vaccines
for cbs this morning anna werner
gardnerville nevada